hello everyone and welcome to a
remarkable game from round one of the
American Cup it's actually game four uh
two of the games they played in
classical time format ended in a draw
then the third game also ended in a draw
and now this is the fourth rapid game or
rather the the second rapid game the
fourth game uh all together uh Wesley so
has the white pieces and Sam shankland
is black so let's check it out features
uh an incredible uh opening the Italian
game or the Joker piano and it's been
analyzed for like 400 years but no one
is safe in this position everyone plays
it when you start playing chess you
learn it because you can easily
Checkmate your opponent in a couple of
moves but also it is played on the
highest level and it has also been
played even in World Chess Championship
match so let's see what happens here
Wesley opens with E4 with E5 Knight to
three Knights the C6 and Bishop to C4
the Italian game is on the board Knight
to F6 the two knights defense and now
not Knight to G5 the movie we're hoping
for but the D3 but in case you were
wondering Knight to G5 indeed is the
second most popular move in this
position Bishop to E7 we have Castles by
both players and now Knight the C3 with
D6 and A4 just grabbing more space on
the queen side as white usually does in
the Joker piano Knight the A5 attacks
the bishop Bishop goes back Bishop to A2
and now Knight the C6 going back with
the Knight the position is a known one
The Raven is is a game from last year's
FTX crypto car between Yankees of Duda
and level narunyan that ended in a draw
uh where C5 was played but after Knight
the C6 it is not as of move a that we
have a completely new game so Sam
looking to mix it up with this weird um
uh Retreat of the Knight so okay H3
stopping G4 we have Bishop to E6 and now
Bishop captures on E6 with f captures
and Knight to E2 now making room for C3
and D4 to be played with A5 stopping B4
very good move by black and now Knight
the G3 we have Pawn to D5 as white
allowed it so of course black will play
it C3 and now Knight to D7 the Knight is
now being re-maneuvered over to C5 uh
the D3 Pawn has been weakened also the
B3 Square might be useful later on plus
it will put additional pressure to E4 so
Rook to E1 and now point the D4 and here
Wesley makes a very interesting decision
uh he plays C captress on D4 which is
kind of undoubling black spawns for free
but he has a very good idea of what he's
doing he captures on D4 and now Pawn to
E5 and now it's a very double-ish
position where uh Wesley indeed uh won
the the E4 Square for his Knight and it
could get really really complicated but
he also allows some ideas like uh Queen
the E8 the G6 putting pressure on the G
file then maybe even Rook captures and
F3 can be played removing one of the
Defenders of the E5 Pawn then maybe
Knight captures and E5 so in exchange
sacrifice let's say for the Knight and
the pawn uh might not be a bad idea for
Sam but Sam just goes Knight to C5 and
now okay he no longer puts pressure on
the east on the E5 Pawn and Wesley grabs
the E4 Square we have Queen to D5 and
now Bishop to G5 attacking the bishop on
E7 so Sam trades with Bishop captures
Knight F captures on G5 Knight captures
an E4 and now Rook captures on e4 and
now it could be a little bit dangerous
if Wesley can get his Queen and Rook
into the attack about Sam just takes
care of it with a nice move like H6 so
Knight back to F3 Rook the F5 now
preparing to double up on the f file and
Rook the C1 now not allowing the Knight
to move as the C7 Pawn would hang uh
Rook 8 to f8 now nicely doubling up and
queen to E2 we have rooked the F4 now
offering a rook trade and Rook the C4 by
Wesley uh really limiting the mobility
of the black queen Rook captures an E4
with Queen captures offering a queen
trade and now uh Rook to d8 Sam says
okay let's trade but um uh if you
capture uh we're gonna trade on my terms
so here King to F1 Wesley knows that
Queens are uh might come off the board
so it better improve the position of
your king as much as possible uh until
then Rook to D7 and now King to E2 with
King to f8 Sam does the same and now
Pawn to H4 we have King to E7 and now
Queen to h7s Sam allowed it but it's not
a really big deal King to F7 the queen
really has no business being on H7 Ponte
H5 now looking for some Queen to G6
check ideas just King to f8 and now uh
Wesley has a a very uh a good move that
it's not easy to find Queen to h8 check
King to F7 and now what would you play
in this position feel free to pause the
video and try to find the the this most
intriguing idea while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on uh realizing
that there's really no danger from black
here and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Queen all the
way to A8 it's not an easy move to make
because you bring your queen all the way
uh away from the action uh but there's
nothing for black to do here uh there's
no way to break through and the rook and
Knight and pawn here are just paralyzing
all of Black's pieces uh the problem is
you're losing the B7 Pawn then the
Knight on C6 becomes weak and the black
has no counter play here there's really
not a move black can play if you play
Knight captures on E5 uh then look at
this Rook captures on D4 and okay the
queen can move it's not a problem but
now Rook F4 check king t7 and queen to
f8 will be Checkmate so that's that's a
big deal so uh after King to F7 Wesley
didn't go for Queen A8 he repeated Queen
to H7 King to f8 and now again this
becomes possible but Wesley first goes
King to F1 and it's actually a good
practical decision whereas this is a
rapid game you don't have all that much
time on the clock it's better to keep
your king safe and then go for such an
idea because there's really nothing for
for Sam to do here but wait what Wesley
will do so King F7 B3 with King to f8
and now Wesley finds it Queen to h8 with
check King to F7 and finally Queen to A8
and now we have King to E7 this is a
very tricky move that prevents a queen
from capturing on B7 because if you play
Queen captures on B7 no there's Knight
captures on E5 it opens up an attack
towards the White Queen so you don't
have time for all that Rook captures and
D4 business so here you would probably
have to trade with capture C capture
throw Caprice and it pretty much trades
down into into a draw so instead after
this um uh uh king t7 move uh uh now or
queen capture Sun B7 doesn't work feel
free to pause the video once again and
try to find pretty much the only idea
that works for white while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations that uh the black uh
figuring out that the black king is now
on E7 and he will not have access to
these three squares uh and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Queen back to G8 incredible but yes
you have to go back and uh disregard the
B7 pawn and now the black king has no
squares and the queen characters on G7
is coming there's just no defense
against that okay Knight captures and E5
was played but it doesn't matter Rook
captures on D4 Queen to C6 now just
Queen captures and G7 with check and now
the big problem is you don't have King
to E8 if you go King to E8 then just
Queen the h8 with check King the E7 and
now Knight captures on E5 this is made
possible because Rook captures on D4 uh
cannot be played because the queen is
hanging but not just because of that
even if you move the queen queen C2
checking you to Queen to C2 checking F3
Queen D1 check uh King to G3 and now
Rook captures on D4 because you kind of
have to win back your piece then just
just Knight the G6 check picks up the
black rook and the white will end up
this line being up a full piece the
beautiful Knight on G6 so instead after
Queen captures on G7 he had to play
Knight to F7 but now it's just uh it's
it's brilliant how uh simply Wesley
makes it seem Rook captures on D7 with
check Queen capture Sun D7 and not
Knights the E5 attacks the queen and
pins the Knight so Queen to d8 E8 the
only move that defends the Knight and
now Pawn to G4 and he was in this
position animal 42 that Sam shankland
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here there's really no
move black and play okay you can play a
couple of pawn moves but uh it's it's a
tube swung ready to to be created
because uh Queen to f8 offering a queen
trade is impossible you just play Knight
to G6 check and black blunder is the
queen and if you don't have this move
you could play some Pawn with C6 but
again it's very very simple to win this
just G5 the Knight cannot move you're
gonna after white creates a pass pawn
and pushes it to Victory that's all
there is to it like B5 You're Gonna Play
H7 let's say black trade ones you can
even recapture that the position is that
good and after G4 you're just gonna
trade everything Knight captures Queen
captures Queen captures King captures
and a simple h8 Queen you're now upper
full Queen
uh so yeah uh after G4 Sam resigned and
a brilliant brilliant uh uh positional
Masterpiece uh by Wesley so in the uh
one of the oldest openings
um ever in chess The Joker piano or or
the Italian game and for those of you
who are interested in the standings from
the other pairings uh this is it Hikaru
Nakamura defeated Samuel 7 and the only
one to win a game in classical time
format uh Levon arunian lost al-nir
Dominguez Perez after three draws and
then losing the game at uh to Lanier
with the black pieces in uh in the
second rapid game uh also the same in
Wesley versus Shanklin three draws and
then Wesley wins with the white piece
and the same as in Fabiano corvana's
game in three draws and then Fabi one
with the white pieces against Ray Robson
so pretty uh uh pretty incredible uh
first uh uh quarterfinal of the of the
American Cup we'll see what happens in
the semi-final uh will there be more
decisive games in In classical or will
players focus more on the rapid chess uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it really uh weird position
where you really have to go Queen to A8
and then after King E7 Queen back to G8
but sometimes you have to do this you
have to realize that there's no danger
and you can just do pretty much whatever
you want and then you know the moves
just come by the by themselves uh so
yeah once again hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Matthew Benoit
Andrea uh Frank Paul hinemund and pan
pan for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the American
Cup and whatever else happens in the
Chess World so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day